you are walking confusion TV
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
deep learning a subset of AI has been
making a lot of waves recently in
previous videos we've seen how deep
neural nets are progressing rapidly
within many fields we've seen this
technology diagnose medical conditions
with more accuracy than trained experts
ai is able to learn from numerous
amounts of data that's what humans can't
do now the accuracy of early detection
of esophageal cancer has reached 90%
learn how to produce sound from scratch
each isn't dough Tsaritsa to certain
pizzas own recreate the visual aspects
of speech we apply the same input speech
map to four different target videos note
that all four uh synthetic and have
different lighting conditions to help
families refinance their homes to invest
in things like high-tech manufacturing
but what is them less known applications
of deep neural nets that could make
their way down to the average consumer
in this video we'll count down five
interesting uses of neural nets in the
context of images and video but first a
quick word from our sponsor this video
is brought to you by audible audible has
a massive range of audiobooks and one of
the best ways to bench content while you
enjoy your summer activities or downtime
one book that I'm listening to at the
moment is super intelligence by Nick
Bostrom the book goes through the
history of artificial intelligence and
the paths that we might take to get to
super intelligence it's a good read and
I recommend it audible is offering you
guys a free audio book with a 30-day
trial membership just go to www.irs.gov
i've photos and videos
normally when you see a black-and-white
image of a time long past it looks dull
distant and unrelatable if you wanted to
colorize that image and make it come to
life it usually requires the effort of a
Keane artist who has a knowledgeable
understanding of the cultural setting in
order to choose the right colors here's
an excerpt from Fox media on how a
colorization artist goes about their
craft since styles of the time are
faithfully represented good people : we
had one guy he's like a specialist
ethnographic dress he was showing like
museum great samples and you know he
lives and breathes this stuff so like
every single little detail like you know
like the color of beads or like a
laplander necklace or something you know
it's really this has got to be the
exactly I think the longest I've spent
on an image is merely months what if
there was a way to do this instantly
well thanks to deep neural networks this
is now possible
let there be color is a neural net
system that automatically restores color
to black and white photos it can also do
the same with video it uses a
convolutional neural network and can
process images of any resolution unlike
previous approaches the deep Learning
Network actually learns patterns that
occur naturally in photos things like
the sky is usually blue and clouds of
white and gray and grass is typically
green etc but it did this itself from
past experience without human
intervention
let there be color color eyes as Firdos
much better than the state of the art
for 100-year old images just take a look
at some samples here
number four pixel enhancing CSI style
you know that thing that they do in
movies and TV crime shows such as CSI
where an investigator demands that a
grainy image be enhanced and somehow
magically it becomes HD all that second
all enhance the zoom in on the door I
know many people get annoyed with such
an unrealistic portrayal of technology
but now this kind of image enhancing is
now possible thanks to neural networks
Google brain researchers have trained a
deep learning neural network to take
very low resolution images of faces and
predict what those faces will most
likely look like they call the method
pixel recursive super resolution and it
enhances the resolution of photos
dramatically in the image below you can
see the original 8x8 photos and in the
middle you can see the guest from the
system obviously it's not perfect and I
don't think it can be but it's pretty
unbelievable that this neural network
can guesstimate so well the features of
the person within a photo number three
generating new images pics to pics
there's a deep learning neural network
that generates new images based on input
but this neural network was trained to
perform multiple but specific tasks
either create real street scenes from
colored shapes or create a drawn map
from an aerial photo or turned a scenes
into night and finally make a
photorealistic image just from an
outline I think the last example is
actually pretty cool the pics depicts
system is as to neural networks arranged
in such a way that one network generates
images and the other network is the
judge of if these images are real or not
these two networks try and fool each
other and improve each other in the
process this setup is known as a
generative adversarial Network if you
want to try out some of this stuff
there's a simple web app created for you
to have a play with the edge outline
part of this neural network links will
be below number 2 lip-reading
lip net is a neural network developed by
oxford university and google deepmind
scientists this network can watch a
silent video of a person talking and
convert the mouth movements directly to
text lip net has raised 95% accuracy in
reading people's lips an average lip
reader has an accuracy of about 50 or 60
percent so that's not bad at all for
living it number one creating a scene
from scratch a team of computer
scientists from institutions such as the
University of Wyoming and ubers AI
department have created what they're
calling plug-and-play generative
networks this system is able to generate
photorealistic images from a selection
of a thousand categories I guess it's
early days for this stuff and some of
them do look a little weird but it's
still cool to see the network try and
figure out how to create a scene from
scratch here's a video of the neural
network running the goal is to generate
the image that's written in text below
and each frame you see in this video is
a different iterative step of trying to
get there it actually kind of looks
beautiful to look at
[Music]
so that pretty much rounds out the video
what application did you like best if
you know of any other cool uses of deep
neural networks feel free to let me know
in the comment section below anyway
thanks for watching this has been - go
go you've been watching cold fusion feel
free to subscribe if you've just
stumbled across this channel and I'll
catch you again soon for the next video
cheers guys have a good one thinking
[Music]
you